foreign
yeah sure
um so Justin I'm very excited to have
you here Justin is a senior machine
learning researcher at Lambda Labs
working on image generation and editing
particularly for artistic and creative
applications and
um his specialty and the thing that I
think I know him for and many of you
might know him for is taking these
pre-trained models and adapting them to
add new capabilities or to come up with
like new use cases so if you've seen for
example text to Pokemon which was a fine
tune of stable diffusion or the image
variations version where you could feed
him an image rather than a text prompt
those are some of his more well-known
projects but he's done lots of other
work as well so Justin really great to
have you here
cool thank you very much
um yeah I'm really excited to be up uh
in this this lineup um so the the talk I
guess I'm gonna give and the title was
was talking about like Beyond text so
sort of other types of kind of input and
conditioning
um other than text and I think we've
heard actually a lot about that in in
some of the previous works so hopefully
it follows on quite nicely
um and I guess yeah just a bit more
background about myself I mean I've been
involved in the sort of like generative
Ai and art and editing side of things
for a few years and it was initially my
hobby where I just do these things in my
spare time but now it's like my my
full-time job at Lambda
um which you might know them better for
sort of selling GPU workstations and
servers and having a GPU Cloud but we
also have a small research group
um both for like public stuff and also
privately for some of our customers as
well
um so I was thinking about the the topic
of my talk which is going to be sort of
presenting a few of these like
experiments um and these things that I
kind of built on top of stable diffusion
um to kind of give extra levels of
control sort of beyond the normal text
input which I guess we're all familiar
with
um but I realized actually that the sort
of higher level message of my talk
um is actually
maybe suggested a different title which
is like the endless hackability of
stable diffusion and I think it's a
really important point that the release
of stable diffusion as an open model
which is of you know reasonable size or
the training code and data available
um has really like opened the doors to
like experimentation and playing with
the model Beyond just you know doing
inference with it
um and I really feel like it stay at the
release of stable diffusion was kind of
like
um a style gun moment for for diffusion
models and text the image generally and
if you're not familiar with style gamut
was this you know really great Dan a few
years ago which was state of the art in
terms of generating like most famously
high resolution images of people's faces
who didn't exist and all the code was
released openly in the model checkpoints
were available and tons of people went
away and trained it on their own domains
or kind of made modifications and and
added new things to it um and it was
really like open the floodgates to
Innovation I think a really similar
thing is happening with staple diffusion
just because of the way the way it's
been released and the way it's
accessible
so I guess going back to the sort of
topic of my talk
um probably most people who've used a
text image model might understand why
why text isn't always enough
um you know often it's great that
there's this this kind of gap between
text and images which means you can be
very concise about what you describe and
um text is kind of ambiguous and sort of
limited in many ways and that's great
because it's sort of easy for us to
produce and often the most exciting
things are when the model interprets
your text in a way you didn't
necessarily intend or understand that
tends to produce lots of these kind of
meme-worthy things that David highlights
that like to present about
um but sometimes it's just plain
frustrating so like imagine trying to
make a nice photograph of a cute kitten
and you don't like the way that the ears
look so you kind of try and prompt it to
have slightly less pointed ears and that
sort of works but then you're trying to
want to make the ears go a little bit
further out to the side that doesn't
doesn't really work and you can stuff a
load of stuff into the prompt and you
still can't make the ears Point outwards
a little bit and it would just be there
probably is a prompt that does it but it
it's just much harder than you know
maybe just drawing a sketch or kind of
dragging the the image around or kind of
moving things around us a different
modality to text
the other thing I think that highlights
um the limitations of text quite well is
this phenomenon of using using artist
names in prompts um which is you know
proved to be somewhat controversial
and I think you know quite often people
aren't necessarily trying to rip off a
particular artist when they're using a
certain name and a prompt sometimes
that's that's probably the case but not
always and I think it's more an
indication of sort of the the
limitations of our vocabulary when it
comes to expressing concisely a sort of
particular visual style you know our
language doesn't really have the
vocabulary to do it and this is why we
use artist names as a proxy for that
because often they have a very clear
visual style and we use one to address
the other
um so I guess I'm going to present a few
sort of experiments and kind of uh
modifications I made to stable diffusion
to maybe explore some of these these
different ways of conditioning the model
Beyond text and hopefully present some
of these which are mostly kind of fun
little hacks and and play things but uh
also point to some of the research in
the area that kind of points the
direction I think that maybe some of the
field is moving in
um so the first one is
um maybe the one that you might have
heard of um
before which is this image variations
version of stable diffusion
um I'm going to talk about what that is
and how it works in a second um but just
to recap on stable diffusion
um
probably everyone is familiar with with
this concept that you know in stable
diffusion you have
um this sort of image generation part so
there's a new net which is this
denoising diffusion model which takes
kind of these noisy latents and denoises
them to uh you know some uh some image
which you have to pass through the
decoder to get the actual image out
um and the kind of important Point here
is that this process is conditional on
some text and the way that text is kind
of introduced into the process is that
you have this clip text encoder which
takes this prompt and produces these
tokens which are kind of a numerical
representation
um of the of the text itself and that
gets fed in that's kind of side
information to the unit while it's
denoising and it can generate something
which matches the problem
um now something that's kind of clear is
that you know this this part isn't um
particularly doesn't need to be text
specific you can essentially rip this
out and replace it with with anything
which generates you know something at
least which is kind of compatible you
know some sort of vectors which you're
going to put into the unit to the side
to to change what it understands of what
you're you're asking it to do
um so one thing that I did kind of
really early on
um soon after stable diffusion was
released actually with the 1.3
checkpoint I think was to sort of rip
out that
um
rip out that text encoder part and
replace it instead with
um the clip image encoder so I didn't
invent this this was actually from the
Dali 2 paper this is how you know the
Dali 2 image generator works it's based
on
um clip image encodings so here you kind
of give a give an input image and you
pass it through the clip image encoder
it produces this
um this Vector which is 768 numbers
which somehow summarizes this image and
it tends to have things like the sort of
content and the objects and maybe the
style of the image that can captured
within it but clearly it's not enough
information to really completely define
what's in that image
um so that gets fed into the unit and
then
you know it learns to generate images
based on those those clip image
embeddings so what happens when you kind
of generate an image with you know this
this different sort of prompt which is
kind of like an image prompt
um or you get out the other end an image
which has a lot of the a lot of
similarity with the the original you
know it has a lot of the same content
they're kind of fruit and bowls and it's
on a table and the stylistically it's
kind of similar as well and but it's not
the same image clearly so this is a kind
of method for making image variations
um and here's a couple more example this
a few more with this painting by Matisse
and then um a frame from a Studio Ghibli
movie
um you can see if we pass those as our
as our prompt we get these kind of
variations on on a theme of the image
it's really nice that you get you know
similar content similar Styles but you
know clearly different compositions
different arrangements and different
details um and you know it's just fun
fun to see these things um and fun to
kind of get maybe inspiration for how
how an image can be reimagined
um but we can also do some other
interesting things
um so one thing which has always
fascinated me with these these sorts of
models is that when we encode an image
so here's here's an example on the top
left of some like black and white photo
of a meeting of kind of military people
um and we encode this with the clip
image um encoder we we kind of put that
into a place called latent space so this
is like numerical Vector is in this
latent space where directions in here
are kind of meaningful and you know
things that are closer are more similar
and things that are far away are more
different
um so if we just encode the image and
then generate a new one based on that
encoding we get you know one of those
variations that we just saw
um but one thing that might be really
interesting to do is if we can move
around in this latent space so kind of
move that Vector in certain directions
we can generate images which maybe are
related to the the original one but
somehow different
but the question is like how can we how
can we tell how to move in this latent
space well one advantage we can take uh
take from clip is that this latent space
is actually shared between text and
images so we can pass in a couple of
prompts to our
um to the text encoder part of clip
which also can project these um these
text phrases into latent space and we
can put in a black and white photo and
color oil painting
um and then that's great we can draw a
line between those two points and that
gives us you know a direction maybe
which points from black and white to
color oil paintings
um then we can just take that Arrow add
it onto our original position to get a
new position in this latent space and
then generate an image from there
and you know we get something which
seems to be an oil painting but has a
lot of the kind of content of the
original image so we kind of we can do
this kind of editing in latent space and
move around it to kind of manipulate our
our images our generated images in a
meaningful way so you can have another
look at a different example old black
and white photo to Modern DSLR photo
um and you get you know a change in
style it kind of looks more modern
there's kind of this like uh depth of
field effect which suggests the DSLR and
this also works for things like content
as well as just style
um so it's really cool though I think
moving around in this latent Space is
really powerful and interesting
um like I say I didn't invent that
either that was from the actually from
originally from the the Dali 2 paper
um so they again showed some examples
where they can you know take take images
and have two prompts which are kind of
different and move in the direction of
that difference between the prompts and
here they actually do it better than me
because they have this nice inversion
method where they can take a real image
and kind of find the noise that will
recreate that image from the image
encoder and then they can actually edit
edit the real image
um so I think that's you know that's
that's really cool and I think the a lot
of what's uh interesting research that
I've kind of seen along these lines
recently as well has been you know
taking that idea of having different
sorts of encodings and kind of uh taking
it further so one recent paper called
versatile diffusion actually takes uh
text and image encodings it also has
some other bells and whistles to it but
it basically means it has this really
adaptable model which can do all sorts
of generations from images to text to
images to images and images to text
images and always around
um another I think really interesting
paper recently was this one edify by
Nvidia
where they take not only clip the clip
decks encoder they also have another
text encoder called T5 and they also use
the clip image encoder and they find
that all of these things kind of impart
different information onto the model
while it's generating images and so then
uh inference time you can swap these
things out and change them and actually
influence you know how your image image
is generated in interesting ways so one
really nice example they have is this
sort of style transfer type of example
they they could generate an image based
on a text prompt with a reference image
and then this middle row is there
generated images of the prompt but in a
particular style from from the reference
image which I think is a really nice
application
um so I really imagine like adding more
kind of encoding and information to the
conditioning of the model might be a
really interesting route in kind of
exerting new sort of dials of control
into these models
so one of the sort of small extension
that I was playing with recently
um was this kind of idea of not just
image variations particularly but face
variations
um sort of inspired by the popularity of
these dream Booth approaches which have
come about recently where you know
people take some images of their face
and then fine-tune a stable diffusion
model on their face with a particular
token and then try and put their face in
new places
um and right now it's it's great but
it's also really terrible you know it
requires fine-tuning the whole model and
you have to store a whole model per
person
um so it seems completely impractical
and
um so I was wondering you know is there
a is there a route to making these
things where it's you know you don't
need to trade a whole new model each
time
um so one one thing that I tried kind of
recently is kind of taking the the
existing approach of having these sort
of clip image encodings
um but actually taking two different
encodings so one kind of specifically
focused on the face region and then one
kind of mask out that face just put a
like gray Square over the top of it and
then
um give clip the rest of the image as
well so maybe and then you generate
these two tokens uh or these two
embeddings from um from that process so
one which hopefully corresponds more to
the face the identity probably also the
expression as well and then the other
one from the surrounding which kind of
corresponds to uh you know the hair the
Hat the lighting or any beard or or
anything else like that
um so you can train this model on a on a
bunch of face data and maybe it'll get
get really good at generating uh
generating faces with these sort of two
two points of control
um so I fine-tuned a model a stable
diffusion model on this and here are a
couple of example faces from this celeb
a data set
um so if we just take those two images
and encode them into those two
embeddings and then just give them as
the condition to
um the clip uh the the image generation
model
hopefully we'll see rows of you know
this same person in in pretty much the
same situation
and yeah it kind of works they're
probably slightly different people
um according to our like Keen sense of
of
um a facial recognition but you know
it's pretty pretty close and pretty
similar
um so one so that's kind of kind of neat
you can sort of generate slight
variations on on pictures of of yourself
maybe
um but what's actually more interesting
is what if you take you know we have
these two different embeddings what if
we take one of them from a different
picture so here we can take uh the
embedding from the sort of facial region
from these two on the left and then the
sort of the embedding from the kind of
external region from these images at the
top and if we mix them together and
generate
then we kind of get this this person is
sort of
um generated you know hopefully
something that's quite close to their
face but with the context of the
surrounding area so it's given you know
long hair or it's introduced the hat or
the messy hair of Peter Jackson
um and this works you know quite well I
wouldn't say it's like the the quality
of dream booth at the moment but it's
you know it's a very interesting
approach it was like you know really
easy thing to do and you know
essentially adapting that that image
variation code and fine-tuning for you
know maybe a day or so
and I feel like there's plenty of scope
here to keep on exploring these ideas
you know either introducing like facial
recognition modules which are more
designed to recognize Dental entity
features or things like that
um and I really think the future of
dream Booth is is not fine-tuning all
these models but it's actually just a
model which takes an image of your face
and can then just put you in put you in
new situations
um and yeah it's kind of also
um recently saw this paper
um
for about exerting more sort of spatial
control so here is a sort of similar
idea that they have a prompt but then
also regions of the image which can have
different different prompts so that you
can kind of be much more controlled
about the structure and composition of
your image so here the the approach is a
bit more sophisticated but the sort of
basic concept is similar
um
so that was like a kind of one type of
um control that you can sort of exert
over these things and they're not
exclusive to
um you know they don't reply they don't
have to replace the text even though I
did it in this case you know often you
can combine those things
um and I think I you know definitely
if you think about all of the types of
sort of these embeddings you can
generate from images whether it's like
facial features or um kind of landmarks
or pose estimations or uh you know
anything else you can think of
um you could use that as a conditioning
for the image generation module and you
can kind of generate new features new
images which have those sorts of
properties
um so I think you know this space is
like really right for exploration and
play
um
so the second half I was going to talk a
bit more briefly but about a different
type of conditioning that you can have
so all of those ones that I just showed
were you know condensing down an image
into you know a small vector or a couple
of small vectors which you use as the
the condition for Generation
Um but there's another approach you can
take which is kind of well explained and
demonstrated by um by this idea of super
resolution so in super resolution you
tend to you want to take a low
resolution low quality image and you
want to generate a high resolution high
quality image that could have made that
low resolution one
um
and so if we look at our previous
diagram of stable diffusion you know the
you saw that that information the
encoded information from the text prompt
came in sort of to the side
um but there's a different route you can
take when you're doing things like super
resolution is that you can take the
whole image as a condition
um and here you have to sort of move it
into this latent space in which um
stable diffusion operates and then
instead of sort of putting it at the
side you just kind of slap it onto the
end of your noisy latents and pass it to
the unit pass them to the unit
altogether so it's sort of implicitly
saying that there's some kind of
point-wise Correspondence between the
sort of condition image that I'm giving
you and the image that I want to
generate
um and then you can generate your train
it to generate a high resolution version
of that image this is a pretty easy
thing to set up for training because you
can pretty easily generate a low quality
image from a high a high resolution
thing you just down sample it and add
some degradations
um so you can pretty easily create the
sort of paired data just that
essentially go in reverse and the really
nice thing is that all the code for this
is already in the stable diffusion
training repos
um because you know all of this has been
done and uh you know in the latent
diffusion paper there's some already
some really nice super resolution
examples
um so I'm not going to talk about this
too much but before there was this
official stable diffusion V2
um super resolution module I I trained
one of these um just fine tuning the
original stable diffusion and you know
you get in the put in a low resolution
image of a cat and you get out a high
resolution image of a cat so it adds
back all of that like fur detail and
texture on the chair or whatever it is
um and depending on how well that shows
up on screen share this is like a zoomed
in version
um and you can see it works it works
pretty well um for those who are used to
looking at like AI generated images if
you look at the whiskers you can see
that they're not not very coherent which
is like one of The Telltale ways of
spotting a generated image
um but it's pretty good and now there
are like these these really high quality
kind of official checkpoints which I
think actually are kind of comparable to
this one I'm showing but does also have
the nice extra feature that you can text
guide that one which is pretty cool
um and you know this is kind of a
generic technique for
um all sorts of decorations that you can
apply to images so there's this nice
paper called palette from a little while
ago it seems like a long time ago at the
pace of things but you know if you apply
degradations like say making your image
grayscale you can train the network to
essentially undo that
um I think applications like that are
really interesting and stuff I haven't
actually seen a great deal you know
think about text guided image
colorization would be like a really
interesting fine tune or adaptation of
stable diffusion which I certainly
haven't seen yet
um and the other the other example is
from you know that kind of seminal
latent diffusion paper which you know as
well as showing this kind of super
resolution approach on the right they
also showed this other nice um nice kind
of version of this where you can give it
a kind of semantic layout
um you know a map of where things should
appear in the image and you can generate
a new image based on that and you know
that gives you this extra level of
control which is really really appealing
so the last thing I was going to show
um is something which is uh kind of
related to the video side of things but
slightly maybe less practical and more
on the kind of interesting uh and
aesthetically pleasing side
um so there's this I was trying to think
of what other kinds of
um image whole image conditioning can
you apply you know clearly you can take
an image and degrade it somehow and
learn to undo that
um but there's this this kind of
well-established technique of next frame
prediction which takes a video and
subtreats it as just a sequence of
frames and so you can train a network to
take in one frame and predict what do
you think the next frame is going to be
given the starting point once you've
trained something that does that you can
really easily generate a video you give
it a real image generate the next frame
and then say okay take that frame that
you just made predict the next frame and
just keep doing that until you've made
this like long long video
and there's some really awesome examples
of that in you know they've been around
for quite a long time
one that I saw a long time ago and found
really you know inspiring is this worked
from Damian Henry where he you know
trained one of these networks on videos
from a trained window and you see these
like beautiful sort of abstract
um images which kind of give the
impression of traveling and you know
don't really don't really have a
photorealistic quality but extremely
interesting and feeling
um and a bunch of other artists who you
know I think are really really talented
uh have shown work like this before so
Mario klingerman and Derek Schultz have
like these really nice examples of these
kind of next frame prediction videos on
different data sets so I thought okay
well that's pretty easy to do I'll just
take my super resolution thing just
replace the high resolution and low
resolution with you know one frame and
the next frame
and then train fine tune stable
diffusion to to do that task and then I
can come up with this next frame
prediction version so I was on a a train
to a conference last week um I just like
spent most of my time capturing short
video clips out the window at various
points to collect a data set
um and then by the time I got home I
could you know adapt my code
um load up the data and split it into
frames from the videos and then let it
train overnight and then when I go back
to it
I could you know give it one example
real frame and then just generate next
frames from all of those you know
recursively and make you know apart from
the first frame they generate all the
rest of the frames uh sort of
artificially and I I threw that first
frame away anyway so this whole video is
just you know generated from this
fine-tuned stable diffusion on training
Windows and I don't know how well it'll
come across on the screen share on the
video
um
but it's kind of amazing and
you can see it on my Twitter profile or
my YouTube
um maybe a higher quality but it's kind
of amazing that it's almost lost
um some of the aesthetic appeal from
those previous videos because it's
almost too good
um I'll try and play it again
we kind of crossed the uncanny valley
and we sort of come out the other side
and it's become a slightly boring train
video again
um which is it's kind of fun um but
maybe maybe defeats the object but the
fun thing is you know because you have
access to this model and you can
manipulate in all sorts of ways you can
actually make videos which are kind of
more interesting than that by by
manipulating things uh you know
manipulating what the inputs to the
models you can make these kind of really
mesmerizing videos where you're kind of
traveling through these completely
fictitious landscapes
and yeah for me this is like super
appealing and super interesting you know
all of this is completely generated from
one frame just predict the next frame
and it keeps on coming up with all these
like crazy strange and fascinating
things which I could I could watch for
hours
um
so I guess the other thing to say about
this is that that's a really hacky way
of making a video with these with these
diffusion models
um like we heard in the previous talk um
and some of these other papers so
there's this video diffusion models
paper as well
um they're a much more sophisticated
better ways of making kind of coherent
uh nice videos over time so often they
used to have things like temporal
convolutions or temporal attention
um but that next frame prediction aspect
is a really easy way of doing it you
know kind of repurposing that existing
model without too much change that you
can generate something and just maybe
overnight's worth of training
um and then finally another sort of
similar application which I thought is
really cool is this like novel view
synthesis that came out with the
diffusion models where you sort of give
an input View and you train a network
train this diffusion model to predict
um you know different angles of those
views which I think is is really quite
amazing that you might be able to look
around an object without having any
access to anything beyond a photo of the
object
um so I guess in sort of conclusion
hopefully that's kind of an overview of
some of the other ways that you can kind
of modify these networks other levers of
control that you can try and exert on
um on stable diffusion
um and also hopefully it gives you an
idea that you know these things are like
really easy to to mess around with and
kind of hack together and fine-tune so
like if you have if you spend some time
learning about how these things work
these are like extremely accessible and
easy I'd like encourage anybody who sort
of wants to go a bit beyond the just
inference or just dream boothing to like
play around with some of these things
and and train new models and and new
capabilities
um so just to kind of recap through
these like image variations models which
I use a new checkpoint for for those
examples which I'll try and upload to
the hugging face Hub probably tomorrow
at this point
um as this face variations things which
I think has potential but I kind of want
to spend some more time working on it
try and get some some high quality
results the super resolution thing which
um you know I'll probably release that
checkpoint at some point but there is
this kind of official
um stable diffusion V2 version
um and then this next frame prediction
thing which I think is really cool but
probably not very useful um but I'll try
and tidy up a notebook so that it's easy
for for people to do these things on
their own on their own videos and their
own data sets
um yeah and with that yeah thank you
very much and you can like find me on
the Lambda blog or on Twitter on on my
own blog which I occasionally update
um and yeah very interested to see what
what other experiments that people might
do
um from here would be thank you
awesome thank you so much Justin for the
really awesome talk
um I I think you you kind of really
encapsulate the hacker you know culture
that has been built around you know
stable diffusion and diffusion models of
like you know maybe we don't have access
to the a TPU Farm but we can still make
you know pretty cool videos
so I think we have time for one question
from the audience so I think this one is
kind of interesting about
um the comment you made about not
necessarily having to always train new
models like you know dream booth and
that you know when we want to you know
adapt a model to our faces on and so the
question is um you know do you think
there will be like thousands of kind of
diffusion models in the future that are
created by individuals like yourself or
do you think that will start to see kind
of like a you know conglomeration where
it's like okay this is like the best
video or the best model for like you
know putting your face in a in a video
or whatever a picture and so on just
curious what you think yeah I think
that's kind of interesting I think like
the the trend tends to be you know at
some point someone with a lot of
resources releases you know a big model
and then there's always scope to make
that big perhaps General model better on
your particular thing that you care
about by fine-tuning it so you know
everyone uses that as a base or maybe a
few bases and make specific models which
are really good but I feel like the sort
of the rule that we kind of learned
based on sort of the way deep learning
scales is that eventually you know
someone with even more resources and
even more data will train an even bigger
or better model which will then sort of
suppress all of those things but then
you know you still have that opportunity
to make that a little bit better as long
as you have the resources to train it or
fine-tune it and for your own specific
kind of use case
um so I think it'll always be the sort
of case that there are these kind of
like progression of sort of you know big
you know I've heard people use these
like terms of foundation models but you
know these big pre-trained models and
then there'll be a whole bunch of sort
of variations or specializations that
people make for their own particular
Niche or on particular applications kind
of on top of those
awesome so I think we should move on and
uh thanks again for a really nice talk
and uh yeah thanks for the time you took
to to talk to the hiking Fest community
and you know there's a few hundred
people watching this online right now so
yeah lots of comics of people
catch you later